Ngày 1 2 10,5,5 tải khoảng trường bá đình, chủ tịch không trinh mên đặc tư nôn độc lập,
khai sinh nước Việt Nam xinh trù cận hoà và cụ lắm một kiến mất mới mở ra với tèm đụ chính các mặt Việt Nam.
Những người đồng xa khó, chính quyền năm trẻ từng taym để thực hiện nghiệm vụ chính trị, chính phù đã cho phép ina,
lên nếu mấy bà mẫu tèm đồng dương, tạo thành nếu mấy bà mẫu tèm Việt Nam để dùng tám.
Ngày ăn bệnh thức tám nếu 1 1,5 tí nhận 1 năm các mặt tháng tám,
cụ hình thu kháng ký sắp lệng 1 2, cho phép in và phát thành bộ tèm đầu tiên của nước Việt Nam độc lập.
Bộ tèm gồm nằm mẫu, khó khóa trinh dung chủ tịch hồ chính mạnh,
lên đầu tiên, thai trự ước Việt Nam xuất hiện trên tèm thần Việt, gắn gồm hình ảnh vì lãnh tụ khai sinh đất nước.
Hòa sĩnh, mỗi sáng đã tiếp tế nên bộ tèm ngày, ím trên vây só với nước mậu, sình là mạng, đò vang, làm và tính.
Mà mẫu tèm có giá chính thức, 2 mẫu cèm phủ thu cho khủy cụ cốc.
Chỉnh tất cả đều ím thằng chữ Việt Nam dân chủ cộng quà.
Hòa sĩnh, sáng đã dụn với tại hoa để vẻ trình dung bác hồ,
với đổ chỉ tiết chính xác và gâu đặc trinh, khu hòa bị điều kiện i đánh thú thống thời đầu đập lập.
Bộ tèm tại hiện đúng mạc hồ trong những người đầu lập nước, chỉ tệ hình hậu, quyền nghiêm.
Sự ra đời của bộ tèm đồng tiên mang của việc Việt Nam là giống sân trên anh chính phát triển của tèm tinh mạc.
Những có tèm ấy đả và sẽ mạng là chính nhân lịch sử, ghi giấu lợi của giân tạo thằng định chủ quyền thiên liên cộng thu của.